Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen zurück aus der Sommerpause...
...denk ich mal, denn die habe ich nicht angekündigt,
aber... ja, ich hab' echt gedacht, dass ich zwischendurch irgendwie dazu komme Videos zu machen,
nur das sollte wohl nicht sein.
Die Leute, die mir auch auf Twitter folgen wissen auch, dass ich nicht nur
auf der faulen Haut gelegen habe. Ich habe an 2 Filmen gearbeitet,
einer hat sogar Ende August im Kino Premiere gefeiert.
An dem anderen arbeiten wir jetzt immer noch.
Ich hab' die Kooperation mit dem WDR beendet
und die Doktor Whatson Videos, die ich letztens gemacht hab' im Sommer,
liefen jetzt im Fernsehen, was auch ziemlich cool ist.
Dann war ich auf der Gamescom und ich hab' noch an anderen Projekten gearbeitet,
die zum Beispiel auf meinem Kanal kommen werden oder damit gar nichts zu tun haben.
Aber die meiste Zeit ging eigentlich wirklich dafür drauf die Filme zu machen, denn
Filme machen ist eigentlich wie YouTube-Videos machen. Beides kostet mich Zeit und Energie.
Und beides gleichzeitig geht einfach nicht immer.
Das tut mir zwar unglaublich Leid, aber das wird sich vermutlich in Zukunft auch nicht wirklich ändern,
denn ich studiere Film an der Uni und ich werde weiter regelmäßig
Filme machen und das kann sein, dass sich das in Zukunft weiter...
Dass die beiden Sachen kollidieren.
Aber gut, jetzt kommen erstmal wieder Doktor Whatson Videos, versprochen.Jetzt geht's endlich weiter.
Jetzt.
Wann ist eigentlich ,,jetzt''?
Also klar. ,,Jetzt'' ist ,,jetzt''.
,,Jetzt'' bezieht sich weder auf die Vergangenheit, noch auf die Zukunft,
sondern auf das, was dazwischen sein muss.
Die Gegenwart.
Und das ist lustig, denn wir Menschen können die Gegenwart überhaupt nicht wahrnehmen.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel mit dem Finger schnippe...
...und dich frage, wann genau ich das gemacht habe,
dann wirst du mindestens eine Zehntelsekunde zu spät reagieren können.
Das ist deine ,,Reaktionszeit''.
Die Zeit, die dein Gehirn benötigt, um einen Reiz (die Bewegung meines Fingers) wahrzunehmen,
im Gehirn zu verarbeiten und eine korrekte Reaktion an die eigenen Muskeln weiterzugeben.
Und die liegt-im Durchschnitt- bei einer Viertelsekunde, wenn man darauf vorbereitet ist.
Beim Autofahren rechnet man sogar mit rund einer Sekunde Reaktionszeit,
bevor der Fahrer überhaupt irgendetwas machen kann.
Aber nur das Wahrnehmen der Realität ohne Reaktion geht interessanterweise viel schneller.
Von dem Zeitpunkt an, an dem die Photonen eines Bildes auf deiner Netzhaut auftauchen,
die dann als Reize über den Sehnerv zur Großhirnrinde weitergeleitet werden,
können teilweise nur 13 Millisekunden vergehen, bis das Bild bewusst in deinem Kopf wahrgenommen wird.
Das ist zwar unglaublich schnell (bis zu 20 Mal schneller als das Blinzeln eines Auges),
aber es ist eben trotzdem nicht sofort.
Und dazu kommt noch, dass Licht und vor allem Schallwellen dich erst einmal erreichen müssen,
bevor du sie überhaupt wahrnehmen kannst.
Schall bewegt sich in Luft zum Beispiel nur einen Meter alle 3 Millisekunden.
Wir leben also dauerhaft in der Vergangenheit.
Wir können ,,jetzt'' gar nicht wahrnehmen weil es schon vorbei ist,
wenn unser Gehirn die Sinne schon verarbeitet hat.
Und trotzdem muss es ihn geben, oder?
Diesen einen Zeitpunkt, der jetzt gerade herrscht.
Aber vielleicht ist das ein Trugschluss.
Dieses Foto hier scheint ein Zeitpunkt eingefroren zu haben.
Der Ball befindet sich genau an einer Stelle im Bild,
aber trotzdem ist es kein Zeitpunkt, sondern ein Zeitraum, den das Bild darstellt
Jede Kamera, egal wie fortschrittlich sie ist, muss Licht für einen gewissen Zeitraum
auf ihren Sensor fallen lassen, um daraus ein Bild generieren zu können.
Je länger die Belichtungszeit ist, desto mehr Licht fällt auf den Sensor.
Wird das Bild nur kurz belichtet, wird es logischerweise dunkler,
dafür aber auch schärfer weil Objekte sich in diesem Zeitraum weniger bewegen können.
Aber das wirft die Frage auf: Kann es einen Zeitpunkt überhaupt geben?
Die kürzeste Zeit, die laut unseren Gesetzen der Physik überhaupt möglich ist,
ist die Planck-Zeit.
5,4 mal 10 hoch minus 44 Sekunden.
Das ist die Zeit, die Licht benötigt, um die Planck-Länge, die phsyikalisch kleinstmögliche Strecke, zurückzulegen.
Kleinere Zeiteinheiten ergeben mit unserem Verständnis von Physik gar keinen Sinn.
Da Zeit nicht mehr fließend wäre, sondern ,,Quantisiert''.
Also in diskreten Sprüngen stattfinden würde.
Und das wissen wir nicht erst seit Planck.
Schon vor 2.500 Jahren haben sich Leute darüber Gedanken gemacht.
Zum Beispiel: Zenon
Ein griechischer Phylosoph, der sich fragte: Wieso fliegt ein Pfeil?
Seine Argumentation war wie folgt:
Zu jedem Zeitpunkt ist ein fliegender Pfeil an einem bestimmten Ort.
Wenn der Pfeil aber nur an einem Ort ist, ist er in Ruhe und bewegt sich nicht,
weil ja keine Zeit vergeht, in der er sich bewegen könnte.
Wenn sich der Pfeil also an jeder Stelle der Strecke in Ruhe befindet, wie kann sich der Pfeil dann trotzdem noch bewegen?
Es ist ein schönes ,,Paradoxon'', auch wenn es sehr einfach durch die Heisenbergsche Unschärferelation auszuhebeln ist.
Aber es veranschaulicht, warum etwas kontinuierliches wie Zeit,
nicht in unendlich viele Zeitpunkte aufgeteilt werden kann.
So etwas wie einen ,,Zeitpunkt'' kann es gar nicht geben,
denn ein Punkt hat keine Dimension.
Und egal wie viele Punkte man aneinanderreiht, man würde nie einen Zeitraum damit füllen können.
Aus unseren Gesetzen der Physik folgt auch, dass Objekte, die einen Vorgang schneller durchleben
als die Planck-Zeit, zu einer Singularität werden würden.
Mit anderen Worten: Zeitpunkte wie ,,jetzt'' oder ,,morgen um 3'' sind ganz genau genommen eine Illusion.
Sie existieren nicht.
Es existieren nur Zeiträume, die länger sind als 5,4 mal 10 hoch minus 44 Sekunden.
Schreibt mir doch in den nächsten Planck-Zeiten mal einen Kommentar unters Video.
Und ansonsten wenn euch die Hintergrundmusik von meinen Videos gefällt,
mein Musiker Novah hat eine neue EP rausgebracht wo die Songs,
die ich sonst in meinen Videos benutze, drin sind, plus noch viele weitere Songs.
Also wenn euch diese Art von Musik gefällt, dann schaut mal in die Videobeschreibung, da ist ein Link dazu
hört auf jeden Fall mal rein
Ansonsten vielen Dank an ,,Schnellgedacht''. Das ist ein Wissenskanal, der Animations-Videos macht
und mir bei diesem Video mit den Animationen geholfen hat, auch vielen Dank dafür.
Link dazu für euch ist unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns nächsten Donnerstag wo ich - Indianerehrenwort - wieder Videos mache.
Wir sehen uns, bis dahin, haut rein euer Cedric, Tschau